Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Ja, wie wichtig Fußball für mich ist, ist, also Atmen kommt davor, Essen auch.
Der Fußball ist in meiner Leben.
Definitiv ist die Fußball-Fan-Kultur sehr männlich dominiert.
Frauen haben da dann aber einen Platz und sie sind auch da und die nehmen sich auch den Raum.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir wollen heute sprechen über weibliche Fußballfans und ein ganz ausgezeichnetes Projekt, was es dazu gibt. Und dazu begrüße ich euch sehr herzlich. Mein Name ist Max Sackob-Ost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass ich eine außerordentlich tolle Runde zusammenstellen konnte. Ich begrüße bei mir zum einen Antje Grabenhorst, Werder-Fan, Teil der Projektleitung von Tastic Females, über die wir heute ausführlich sprechen wollen, im Vorstand von Fußballfans gegen Homophobie und bei Frauen im Fußball aktiv und auch bei ganz vielen anderen Dingen. Eine Tausend, gibt es einen weiblichen Tausend? Nein, noch nicht. Antje, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Außerdem mit dabei ist Sue Rudolf, Fortuna-Fan, Teil der Projekt-Crew von Tastic Females. Sie ist die Ad-Medien-Freundin auf Twitter und auch bei Frauen im Fußball aktiv. Unter anderem Servus Sue. Hallo. Und neben mir in den Giesinger Studis, das hat eine besondere, feine Note. Steffi Dilber. Warum diese feine Note? Weil sie ist 1860 Fan, auch Teil der Projekt-Crew und bei den Football-Supporters Europe im Vorstand. Servus Steffi. Ich hoffe, du hältst es aus hier in einer roten Höhle, in einer Engklave im blauen Giesing.
Die ist auch wirklich eine Rampensau. Und die hat auch erzählt, also in ihrem Interview, dass sie da in den 70er Jahren, glaube ich, war es, irgendwie so Sprüche bekommen hat von wegen, was willst du denn hier? Weißt dein Mann, dass du hier bist, geht zurück in die Küche. Und dann hat sie angefangen zu singen, you never keep me quiet, you never keep me quiet. Also du kriegst mich nicht leise so, du kriegst mich nicht klein. Und hat auch da in dem Fall mit dem Gesang irgendwie eine ganz lustige Geschichte, weil sie immer Arsenal-Lieder selber dichtet und das ganze Stadion um sie herum unterhält. Und auch eben auf diesen Punkten, sie hat kein Heimspiel verpasst. Als wir den Kick-Off hatten in Hamburg, die Ausstellungseröffnung, haben wir ja verschiedene Frauen aus den Ländern zusammengebracht. Alle, die wollten, haben wir gesagt, haben wir eingeladen, um sich zu vernetzen, kennenzulernen und so weiter. Und sie musste dann halt aber auch an dem Samstag schon wieder weg, weil sie nämlich ein Legends-Spiel von Arsenal nicht verpassen wollte, was ganz niedlich war.
Ja, aber unglaublich. Was waren denn so neben jetzt ihr, das konnte man schon am Trailer und so weiter sehen, welche Rolle sie da gespielt hat. Sue, fang du vielleicht mal an, was waren denn so die Portraits, die bei dir hängen geblieben sind oder die dich vielleicht auch am meisten überrascht haben?
Ja, am meisten überrascht eigentlich einfach so die Vielfalt und die Normalität, aber auch so, wie anders das in anderen Ländern ist. Also, dass man so immer wieder neu überlegt und auch so dadurch reflektierend über sich und die eigene Sozialisation viel lernt. Und einfach auch dieser Mut und einfach das Überraschendste fand ich einfach, wie viele tolle Frauen es einfach gibt. Und dann, dass es mich überrascht hat, dass es so viele tollen Frauen gibt. Es war einfach auch so ein wahnsinniger Lernprozess dabei. Und einfach auch, man kriegt das zwar auch durch Fernsehen und so weiter mit, wie viele verschiedene Fanszenen es gibt und dass die Fankultur in anderen Ländern anders ist, aber das so selber mal mitzuerleben und einfach auch mit so vielen Leuten zu sprechen und so die Kontakte, die sich daraus ergeben haben. Also das fand ich eigentlich so, hat mir am meisten mitgegeben. Also da würde ich gar nicht so einzelne Personen so auspicken, aber vielleicht auch so, also wir haben jetzt auch eine Transgenderfrau dabei und wie so der Weg ist oder eine Rollstuhlfahrerin, wie das so ist, dass man sich auch mal wieder so andere Wirklichkeiten vorstellt und was für andere Probleme es da gibt. Und wie toll die Menschen damit umgehen und was sie daraus machen. Und dass das halt auch in Ländern wie Russland zum Beispiel dann auch möglich ist. Und dass in solchen Fanszenen dann auch man gegen Diskriminierung arbeitet und so weiter. Und was das dann halt einfach so für eine andere Realität ist. Aber ansonsten, ich weiß nicht, so einzelne würde ich da ungern rauspicken, auch weil das einfach so ein rundes Gesamtwerk ist, sag ich jetzt mal.
Aber wie weit gehen denn da die Unterschiede auseinander? Also mit Russland hast du ja schon Land angesprochen, wo wir jetzt alle wissen, auch wegen der WM hat man sich ja noch mal damit besser befasst und eindrücklicher, wie da eben die Gesellschaft aufgebaut ist. Und da siehst du eben, das ist noch eine ganz andere Realität und Gesellschaft als vergleichbar hier mit unseren westeuropäischen Ländern. Was sind denn so die krassen Unterschiede?
Schön, dass ich mich da so reingräte. Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Druckschluss. Die beiden Beispiele, die mich am meisten geprägt haben oder die mir am meisten in Erinnerung geblieben sind, waren Schweden und Türkei. Also Türkei als erste Reise natürlich auch noch mal sehr besonders und intensiv. Aber auch eben das Bild von der Türkei, was ich so habe und was natürlich auch irgendwie der Realität entspricht. Also mit einem sehr autoritären Staat, wo Meinungs- und Pressefreiheit sehr eingeschränkt ist und wo wir trotzdem Frauen getroffen haben. Und auch einen Trans-Mann, der aus seiner Perspektive gesprochen hat, im Vergleich zu wie war es als Frau und wie ist es heute teilweise. Also was wir für Menschen da kennengelernt haben, die super selbstbewusst sind, die sehr modern, sage ich jetzt auch mal, leben und ihre Fan-Identität ausleben, sich engagieren politisch im Fußball. Das sozusagen ihr Bereich ist auch, wo sie aktiv sind, wo sie gegen Passo liegt, die Fan-Karte protestieren oder auch ihre Spiele nicht mehr besuchen können. Deswegen wie von zum Beispiel von Fenerbahce. Also da haben wir super interessante Frauen getroffen, wie gesagt, die mich teilweise sehr überrascht haben. Also ich habe jetzt nicht an mich gestöhnen und introvertierten Frauen erwartet, aber trotzdem in dem darauf bezogen, was für eine Lebensrealität oder in welchem Staat sie ja auch leben. Und im Gegensatz dazu in Schweden, wo ich dachte, ja, ist ein sehr liberales Land, sozusagen sehr weltoffen, sehr, sei er auch demokratisch sozusagen oder sozial, die Struktur da, die Gesellschaft. Und da ist Fußball tatsächlich so ein richtiges Reservat von Männlichkeit. Also vielleicht auch gerade weil das Land so, was Gleichberechtigung zum Beispiel angeht, so weit entwickelt schon ist, dass es dann trotzdem nochmal so Spots bilden wie im Fußball, wo man dann irgendwie die Männlichkeit oder männliche Werte oder konservative Art ausleben kann. Und da gibt es ganz viele Frauen, die sich da selber organisiert haben, wie zum Beispiel Malmö, die wir interviewt haben, die eine Frauen-Fangruppe gegründet haben. Oder es ist auch fast schon ultra-nahe Frauen-Ultra-Gruppe. Malmö-Sistra heißen die. Es gibt verschiedene Sistra-Gruppen auch in Schweden inzwischen, die sich organisiert haben, weil sie nicht in diese Ultra-Gruppen dürfen, weil sie ausgeschlossen werden. Also ganz, ganz massiv und noch viel krasser, als ich das jetzt in Deutschland oder vielleicht sogar in der Türkei wahrgenommen habe. Und da musste ich auf jeden Fall auch erst mal schlucken und dachte, wow. Erst dachte ich halt, geil, es gibt Frauen, die sind halt selbstbewusst, die gehen zum Fußball und sind sichtbar und toll. Die empowern sich gegenseitig und sind Schwestern halt füreinander. Aber das hatte so einen bitteren Beigeschmack auch dann. Und das sind so die beiden Beispiele, wo ich sage, es ist manchmal eben doch nicht so eindeutig. Andererseits haben wir da auch eine Frau interviewt, die ist in Göteborg über den Weg gelaufen. Da hatten wir keine Ansprechpartnerin, weil die abgesprungen ist. Und die ist Jahrgang 1944 und hat uns dann, die konnte gar kein Englisch, hat uns auf Schwedisch da total unterhalten und erzählt, dass sie immer von einer Brüstung fällt, weil sie so doll supportet und die Lieder da trellert, obwohl sie gar nicht singen kann, aber es ist ihr auch scheißegal. Also eine richtige heftige Rampensau einfach. Also ja, sehr, sehr diverse Porträts. Man kann sich das ungefähr vorstellen. Für jedes Land haben wir ungefähr solche Geschichten auch, die die Frauen ausmachen und erzählen.
Ja, aber das fand ich auch gerade das Tolle, also das so in Schweden, also das ist quasi die größte weibliche Ultra-Gruppe in Europa und die hat sich halt gebildet, weil da die Frauen in die Männlich nicht rein durften. Oder auch in der Türkei, wo halt so viel Repressionen gibt, wie anders die Leute damit umgehen. Also auch hier bei Gesi-Protesten und so weiter. Also die selbstverständlich, die da in die Tränengras-Garnaten reinlaufen, als ob das so nix wäre. Und also wir waren auch mit Football-Supporters Europe während des Putsches, hatten wir da unseren Fan-Kongress in Izmir. Das war auch sehr interessant. Und einfach mit Becher, also Seelenruhe und organisiert halt, die ganzen Leute damit umgegangen sind, so als ob das jeden Tag passieren würde, weil die das halt wirklich so aus dem Fußball gewohnt sind. Also es hat mich schon sehr beeindruckt. Also da merkt man wieder irgendwie, je stärker man unterdrückt wird, desto aktiver und stärker geht man eigentlich daraus hervor. Also das hat mir auch immer sehr viel Mut gemacht. Also das finde ich auch so ganz faszinierend.
Man kriegt die Menschen nicht klein. Antje, hast du schon so ein bisschen von deinen Überraschungen erzählt, deinen kulturellen Überraschungen. Gibt es auch so Portraits, die für dich irgendwie einfach hängen geblieben sind? Ich vermute, dass man ja auch manchmal, wenn man die Interviews geführt hat, einfach auf einer menschlichen Ebene kennt man ja, manchmal klickt es bei Leuten. Und dann bleiben die einem vielleicht sogar für immer im Gedächtnis.
Ach glaub mal, dass mir alle Frauen im Gedächtnis bleiben. Wir haben, also ich kenne quasi die Namen auswendig, deren Berufe, deren Vereine und Geburtsdaten, weil ich halt über ein Jahr lang tatsächlich fast jeden Tag mit diesen Frauen den Portraits zu tun hatte, weil wir mit unseren wunderbaren Filmemacherinnen halt immer im ständigen Austausch waren, wie geschnitten wird, was geschnitten wird, ob das Portrait schon fertig ist und so weiter. Also ich habe zu eigentlich fast jeder Frau, auch selbst wenn ich gar nicht beim Interview dabei war, eine sehr persönliche Beziehung schon fast und auch schon fast eine Freundschaft. Das hat sich auch sehr bewahrheitet dann, als wir diesen Kickoff hatten und ich die dann auch kennengelernt habe, dass es da irgendwie total schnell eine diepe und persönliche Ebene so gab. Es gibt natürlich auch so persönliche Interviews oder Frauen, mit denen ich nochmal mehr im Austausch bin als mit anderen, aber eigentlich sind die Frauen komplett präsent einfach.
Das fand ich aber auch eh, als alle zusammen kamen, gab es direkt so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl so. Also da gab es überhaupt keine Berührungsängste zwischen Jung, Alt und Sprachbarrieren, sonst was. Also man war direkt so eins. Also das fand ich auch echt schön.
Ja, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Das wird ja wahrscheinlich auch so der schönste Nebeneffekt dieser Ausstellung sein, dass man eben nicht nur in einem positiven Kontext Frauen in den Stadien zeigt, sondern durch dieses Sichtbarmachen hast du ja auch ein Vernetzungsgefühl. Auch bei denjenigen, die jetzt nicht mit dabei waren, hätte ich jetzt so von außen zumindest reininterpretiert, dass es sichtbar wird.
Du meinst jetzt nicht mit dabei waren?
Nee, bei denen, die quasi nicht interviewt wurden. Also es gibt ja viele Frauen in Fernkufen. Und wenn du jetzt aber dann diese leuchtenden Beispiele siehst, oder vielleicht auch manchmal die ganz, die Beispiele, bei denen es ganz normal ist, dass man als Frau sich auch in Ultra-Gruppen und so weiter engagiert, ich glaube, dass es einfach gut ist, solche Biografien sichtbar zu machen, weil es eben halt doch noch die Minderheit ist.
Ja, natürlich, dass ja auch dieser Vorbild-Effekt, den ich schon mal angesprochen habe, dass man einfach sieht. Oder auch gerade für die junge Generation, also selbst wenn es im eigenen Verein vielleicht noch nicht so ist, man sieht, es kann so sein, es ist woanders so. Und warum soll ich nicht auch so sein? Also bei der Ausstellungseröffnung gab es auch so ein kleines Mädchen, die es durch die Ausstellung durch hat, das alles in sich aufgesaugt und dann so zu ihrem Vater gesagt, so wer weiß, in ein paar Jahren bin ich auch eine Tastic Female. Und da wird mir jetzt schon wieder, da habe ich fast angefangen zu heulen. Das war so schön, also ja.
Steffi, bei wie vielen Interviews warst du denn mit dabei und was ist dir so in Erinnerung geblieben?
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe es leider nicht geschafft zu dem Interview und ich habe es auch nicht zur Ausstellungseröffnung geschafft. Und deswegen ist das einzige Interview, wo ich dabei war, mein eigenes und das ist auch das Einzige, was ich bisher gesehen habe, leider, ja. Ja, ja, ich freue mich. Und ja, sie endlich mal zu sehen. Also wenn sie nach München kommt, aber vielleicht schaffe ich es vorher auch, aber die ist so weit weg.
Ja, das kommt uns ja vielleicht genau zu der Frage, nämlich wann man die Ausstellung wo sehen kann. Wer möchte sie beantworten? Antje?
Ich könnte auf jeden Fall. Also wenn ihr ein bisschen Zeit habt, es gibt auf jeden Fall eine lange Tourliste.
Wird natürlich auch verlinkt, also auch wenn ihr diese Folge hier erst, was weiß ich, im Februar 2019 hört, dann schaut in die Show Notes der Link zu den Tour-Daten dieser Ausstellung wird zu finden sein.
Oder auf www.fantasticfemales.org, da findet man das auch alle.
Genau, zwischen den Fan-Tastic und Females immer bitte einen Bindestrich machen, weil sonst ist es schwierig, die zu finden. Ja, also ich werde jetzt nicht die ganze Liste runterrattern, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall morgen und auch heute noch in Bochum. Morgen findet auch abends eine Podiumsdiskussion statt.
Also das ist dann der 17. und 18. Dezember?
Genau, genau, stimmt.
Jetzt muss ich schnell veröffentlichen.
Genau, danach sind wir in Bremen unterwegs, also vom quasi 24. bis 3.11. Und danach geht's nach Trier weiter ins Borosseum nach Dortmund. Wir machen noch einen kleinen Schlenker über Ostdeutschland, Halle und Leipzig. Das wird dann im Dezember und Januar gezeigt. Oder da findet das statt. Wir werden weiterziehen nach Fürth und Wohlen, also dann in die Schweiz. Also der erste quasi Länderpunkt aus der Zeit von Deutschland. Dann machen wir dann nach Bern, Zürich, München, München-Roth in der Stelle.
Da können ja auch Blaue hin, Steffi.
Na, wenn ich mir nicht so sicher bin.
Wenn du willst, dann einfach zu zweit und dann werde ich mich heldenhaft.
Ich setze mir eine rote Mütze auf den Kopf.
Ja, außerdem bist du eine fantastische Female.
Eben, ganz genau.
Hallo.
Find ich auch.
Genau, dann haben wir noch Stuttgart, Freiburg, Mainz und Gelsenkirchen für nächstes Jahr auf dem Zettel bis, ja, weiß ich nicht, März, glaube ich, soweit und Jena und Babelsberg für in Juni. Und genau, es geht immer weiter.
Und danach kommt bald Düsseldorf dann Anfang der nächsten Saison.
Genau, wenn man dann den Klassenerhalt feiert, dann ist auch die Ausstellung da. Ihr habt auch die ganze Ausstellung von der Machart darauf ausgelegt, dass sie eben in ganz verschiedenen Umgebungen gezeigt werden kann. Und man kann sich eben auch darum bemühen, dass die Ausstellung zu einem selbst in die Nähe kommt. Was muss man denn dafür tun?
Ihr solltet erstmal ganz viel Bock haben. Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Und dann eine E-Mail an exhibition.fanseurope.org schreiben. Und zwar erstmal sagen, dass ihr Bock habt. Und, ähm, wer ihr seid, vielleicht auch schon möglichst, ähm, welche Räumlichkeiten ihr habt, ob ihr eine Fan-Gruppe seid oder ein Museum oder ein Verein, ist auch immer wichtig, weil auch je nachdem geguckt wird, wie viel, sozusagen, ihr bezahlen müsst. Also es ist generell keine teure Ausstellung. Es gibt eine Grundmiete. Wenn ihr ein Rahmenprogramm macht mit Vorträgen oder Napoleon-Diskussionen, ist es auf jeden Fall auch günstiger, weil wir die Leute ermutigen wollen, auch über Frauen im Fußball sich auszutauschen. Und alles Weitere, Datum, natürlich Wunschzeitraum mit angeben. Alles Weitere wird dann in der Mail-Korrespondenz geklärt, sozusagen.
Und warum haben euch noch nicht alle Bundesliga-Vereine die Türen eingerannt? Oder haben sie euch die Türen schon eingerannt und ihr habt aus irgendwelchen Gründen gesagt, nee danke, wir wollen es anders machen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also sie haben euch noch nicht die Türen eingerannt?
Nee, es sind tatsächlich auch wenig Vereine jetzt sozusagen, wo ich sage, ich weiß nicht, die Namu Dresden, der Verein hat uns offiziell angesprochen, sondern es sind viele Fan-Projekte, die da sehr interessiert dran sind. Es sind viele Fan-Gruppen. Primär sind es eigentlich Fans, die sagen, wir machen das. Und ich glaube vielleicht kommen dann die Vereine irgendwann mal dazu. Aber ich schätze einfach, das ist auch ein Ding, was Fans interessiert, wo Fans daran Interesse haben, viel mehr als in einem Verein einfach.
Was ja auch nicht unbedingt schlecht ist, dadurch entstehen ja auch viele, dass Fans mit den Vereinen zusammen vielleicht was machen oder unterstützt werden im Nachhinein. Oder dass wieder mehr der berühmte Club-Fan-Dialog etwas belebt wird. Wir wollen ja auch Frauen stärken und Vereine zum Nachdenken bringen, warum sie keine Frauen in ihren Reihen haben. Das ist dann auch so ein schöner Nebeneffekt, dass dann da quasi so eine Diskussion angestoßen wird.
Aber gibt es da wirklich Vereine, die sich da Gedanken machen und die das interessiert? Ja, habe ich gerade überlegt. Also bei meinem Verein kann ich mir das gar nicht vorstellen. Jetzt überlege ich gerade, ob mein Verein einfach nur negativ ist oder?
Werder Bremen, ich will jetzt nicht alles irgendwie teasern oder spoilern, weil ihr seid positiv. Die haben auf jeden Fall gesagt, sie wollen das an den Start holen. Und das ist die Fernabteilung, die sozusagen der Verein auch ist oder der Bremen-Verein vertritt. Die haben das nach Bremen geholt. Da ist vielleicht auch, ja.
Ja gut, Bremen hat eine große Fernabteilung oder Fernbetreuung auch, die sind auch sehr aktiv, das stimmt schon.
Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, auch zu Frauen, was ist das? Ist es WM nächstes Jahr? Genau, in Frankreich, dass es da auch nochmal ausgestellt wird, dass da sich die Leute mit einbringen. Ich glaube, es wird nicht der letzte Verein gewesen sein, der sagt, das ist für uns relevant.
Ja, das Problem ist halt eben, es sind halt verschiedene Frauen von anderen Vereinen. Die Frage ist, ob das dann die Verein interessiert. Was interessieren mich Fans von anderen Vereinen? Also ich gehe jetzt mal vor meinem Verein, das sagt sowieso, was interessieren mich Fans groß im Grunde genommen. Und dann noch, wenn sie nicht von 60 Fans sind, dann interessieren die mich eigentlich gar nicht. Also bei meinem Verein würde ich das dann eher so einschätzen, warum sollte ich das machen? Das bringt mir nichts, das bringt mir keine zahlenden Kunden.
Ja und um so eine kleine Bresche zu schlagen, also ist ja auch oft so, dass dann zum Beispiel der Vorstandspräsident sagt, es ist ja eigentlich Aufgabe der Fanbetreuung oder eher, dass die Fanbetreuung dann vielleicht, naja, ist ja vielleicht Sache der Fanprojekte. Also jetzt im Fall von Fortuna sind alle daran interessiert, uns zu unterstützen, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das auch so ein bisschen hin und her geschoben wird und dann muss halt einer mal ansprechen und da ist es halt auch, kommt immer darauf an, auch wie die Fans quasi im Verein organisiert sind, ob man miteinander spricht und ob das jemand erzählt. Also so, gibt ja auch immer so, das haben wir nicht mitbekommen und also das muss dann auch einfach mal angestoßen und angesprochen werden. Also aus meiner bisherigen Erfahrung ist eigentlich, wenn man so was anspricht, vorschlägt und irgendwie am besten schon ein bisschen Plan hat, dann wird man da auch bei unterstützt.
Die steigen dann irgendwann auch, glaube ich, mit ein. Also manche Vereine zumindest geben Kohle oder stellen irgendwie Räumlichkeiten usw. Aber es ist wie mit vielen fanpolitischen Themen oder Themen im Antidiskriminierungsbereich, dass dann erst mal das von den Fans kommen muss. Also auch diese gesamte Diskussion um Rassismus im Fußball. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Vereine gesagt haben, das nervt uns, sondern sie sagen erst, es nervt uns, wenn irgendwie die Stimmung, wenn die Medien darauf aufmerksam werden, wenn die Stimmung scheiße ist und wenn das sich nicht mehr verkaufen lässt. Das ist halt die Realität auch leider. Und dann muss man damit irgendwie dealen und sich nicht davon abhalten lassen, dass man doch Bock hat, auf das Thema oder die Themen auf die Agenda zu bringen.
Ja oder man muss es halt wie immer einfach für den Verein einfacher zu machen, das zu tun, was man möchte, als es nicht zu tun. Also da kann man ja auch dann als Fanszene mit dran arbeiten.
Klar, ich meine, erklärbar ist das irgendwie schon. Ich finde, es hört sich nur so an, als ob das immer noch wahnsinnig viel Aufwand für euch wäre, dieses Ding, was ja jetzt gerade angelaufen ist, diese Ausstellung, weiter zu verbreiten und am Laufen zu halten. Und es gibt viele Tour-Daten, aber das hört sich für mich immer noch nach sehr viel Aufwand an, den ihr da betreiben müsst. Und da frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt schon, warum da nicht einfach eine DFL kommt und sagt, wir finden das so super, wir nehmen euch davon jetzt einfach so viel ihr mögt ab. Also die sollen jetzt ja nicht so sagen, wir haben das gemacht. Das wäre auch Quatsch, wollt ihr ja auch nicht. Aber das finde ich schon erstaunlich, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber da muss sich die DFL auch an der Stelle neben dem Lob und dem Dank, dass sie uns finanziell unterstützt haben, auch mal ein bisschen aus der Kritik sozusagen nehmen. Weil die auch gesagt haben, wir haben da eine Mischel der Versammlung, wir würden voll gerne die Ausstellung da zeigen. Da ist sie dann parallel in dem Zeitraum gerade in Halle. Aber die haben auch überlegt, ob sie es nachdrucken sollen. Und ja, die sind da schon so, dass sie sagen, ey, wir finden das Thema so super. Und wir wollen das einfach auch sichtbar machen und zeigen. Also da haben wir noch quasi die meiste positive Rückmeldung. Und bei allen anderen Vereinen, das muss halt irgendwie, da muss einer mal in der Ausstellung gewesen sein und sehen, wie toll das ist.
Also die Initiative muss kommen, das können ja alle Hörerinnen und Hörer übernehmen. Dann seid ihr ausgebucht und das stellt automatisch auch die Frage, wie geht es jetzt denn dann eigentlich weiter? Ihr habt vorhin schon angedeutet, dass ihr noch einige Interviewpartner oder auch vielleicht sogar schon geführte Interviews, weiß ich nicht, im Petto habt noch für die Zukunft. Wird nicht die letzte Ausstellung gewesen sein, sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist die Frage. Die Zeit wird es uns erzählen mit der Zeit. Ich weiß es nicht genau, ob es jetzt das letzte Interview gewesen ist, was wir gemacht haben, oder ob da noch ein Fantastic-Females 2.0 in fünf Jahren, in zehn Jahren, wann auch immer, drangehangen wird. Jetzt sind wir gerade also aus der Projektgruppe primär erst mal froh, dass wir diese zweieinhalb Jahre intensive Arbeit erst mal durch haben. Und wie gesagt, was du ja auch meintest, da hängt auch immer noch sehr viel Organisation gerade dran. Und wir reisen ja auch teilweise mit und stellen die Ausstellung vor Ort dann irgendwie auch mit vor. Wenn sich Leute finden und sagen, ich habe da eine prickelnde Idee, können wir auch darüber reden, die zu erweitern. Allerdings ist es jetzt schon so, dass wir 50 Panel haben, so Roll-Up-Banner. Das ist schon schwierig, wenn man die auf 100 oder so erweitert, weil man dann irgendwann mit einem Lastwagen, glaube ich, von A nach B fahren muss. Ja genau, das ist alles offen. Wir sind auch offen für Vorschläge. Es ist immer nur die Frage, wer macht es und wie macht man es, woher kommt die Kohle und die Energie. Aber wir sind da offen. Total, die Reise hat gerade erst begonnen.
Ja, im buchstäblichen Sinne ja, bei einer Ausstellung, die jetzt schon Tordaten auf ihrer Seite hat. Ihr habt das ja bewusst so gehalten, dass man alle Porträts sehen kann, allerdings nur, wenn man auch vor Ort die Ausstellung gesehen hat. Das kann man, glaube ich, auch ganz gut eigentlich nachvollziehen, warum dem so ist. Habt ihr denn den Plan aus dem Material, was ihr habt, vielleicht noch was anderes zu machen? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn ihr so lange tolle Interviews geführt habt, ihr habt ja auch ganz viele szenische Shots, zumindest im Trailer waren sehr schöne mit dabei, könnte man ja rein theoretisch auch ein filmisches Projekt draus machen.
Ja, das ist der Witz daran, dass immer alle denken, das ist ein Film, mich immer alle angesprochen haben, wann kommt denn euer Film aus?
Das ist, wenn man einen zu guten Trailer macht.
Wie gesagt, wir haben wunderbare Filmemacherinnen, Cutterinnen da am Start, die glaube ich auch super viel ehrenamtlich gearbeitet haben und Zeit investiert haben, glaube ich auch erst mal eine Pause gerade brauchen. Wenn die Bock haben und die Kohle auftreiben, kann man natürlich aus dem Material, wie du sagst, einen Dokumentarfilm machen. Man kann glaube ich eine zehnstündige Doku-Reihe irgendwie auch machen, weil wir haben einfach super viel Material. Ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Stunden das sind, aber lass es tausend Stunden sein. Klar kann man das voll machen. Ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht, wir haben diese ganzen Interviews transkribiert oder transkribieren lassen, auch mit unseren ehrenamtlichen Helferinnen und Helfern. Man könnte auch gucken, ob man da eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit rausstreckt, ob man ein Buch daraus strickt, allerdings war für uns auch der Grund zu sagen, man kann es nur vor Ort sehen und nicht online, dass wir auch die Leute und die Geschichten ein bisschen schützen wollen. Und nicht jeden einzelnen Satz und jede einzelne Frau so sichtbar machen. Klar, in der Ausstellung sichtbar machen, aber die sollen immer noch ein bisschen dadurch kontrollierbar sein, wer das sieht, durch den Rahmen der Ausstellung.
Ja, genau, das wollte ich vorhin so angedeutet haben, ihr könntet doch einfach einen Podcast machen. Und dann ruft er die Frauen, die Lust haben, sich auf dieses öffentliche Medium einzulassen, ruft er dann nochmal an und redet einfach nett miteinander. Das wäre doch was.
Das wäre total was. Ich glaube, da gehören noch einige Frauen dabei, das zu tun, definitiv. Also wir die allermeisten haben es ja auf Deutsch gemacht, Interview oder auf Englisch. Also wir haben nur ein paar Ausnahmen, wo wir es dann übersetzen müssen, würde sich anbieten. Also wenn jemand von den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern da Lust hat, wir sind da offen.
Ich würde euch sofort helfen. Noch schöner fände ich es allerdings, wenn sich eine Hörerin melden würde, weil wir brauchen mehr Frauen hinter dem Mikros. Aber wir bleiben zu dem Thema auf jeden Fall in Kontakt. Es soll nicht daran scheitern, dass es euch an irgendetwas fehlt. Also da kann ich bei allem unterstützen. Ich buche das gleich mal ein. In der Portfolio wird bald da ein Podcast auftauchen. Und bald ist ein dehnbarer Begriff. fantasticfemales.org Das ist die Webseite, auf die ihr gehen müsst, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wenn euch das Thema interessiert und besucht vor allem dann die Ausstellung, worüber ich jetzt, wenn ich schon so eine illustre Runde hier zusammen habe, gerne reden würde, ist noch generell das Thema weibliche Fans in den Stadien im Fußball. Steffi, wie männlich würdest du denn sagen, ist denn der Fußball im Jahr 2000 noch? Du siehst ja schon meine erste Frage, das ist ein bisschen doof.
Ja, gerade heute erst gelesen, eben lustigerweise. Beim letzten Auswärtsspiel von 60, im Meppen, kam dann natürlich wieder der Fan-Gesang, Fußball ist ein Männersport.
Gegen wen hat der sich denn gerichtet?
Anscheinend gegen die Schiedsrichterin. Ja, genau. Und da, wie du sagst, Antje, what? Ich hab das auch gelesen, was? Ganz genau, richtig, ganz genau, ganz genau, ganz genau. Und da fällt einem dann nichts mehr ein. Das ist dann meine Antwort auf diese Frage. So männlich ist der Fußball. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, wenn ich das so höre, was Antje erzählt, was Sue erzählt, eben auch von St. Pauli, das ist wirklich vom Standort auch abhängig. Die Szenen sind unterschiedlich, die Fangemeinden sind unterschiedlich. Ich glaube, da gibt es wirklich riesige Unterschiede, wie in den verschiedenen Ländern eben auch. Und das hängt ja wirklich davon ab eben auch. Es ist ja schon durchgeklungen bei uns. Bei 60 ist halt, ja, was heißt männlich, aber da ist schon ganz klar das Männliche dominiert. Aber eben, es wird schon langsam. Und eben, es werden mehr Frauen akzeptiert und machen auch. Und das wird schon langsam. Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein langer Weg, diese verkrusteten Strukturen oder eben diese Strukturen einfach aufzubrechen oder sich zu verändern. Da wären sich alle dagegen. Das ist einfach schwierig, ja.
Würdest du sagen, das geht parallel zur gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung, wo ja schon Emanzipation ein Thema ist, oder geht es im Fußball langsamer oder schneller?
Es geht schon parallel, aber es ist ein bisschen hinterher, weil Fußball einfach generell von vornherein eben ein wesentlich männlicher besetztes Feld ist, als die Gesellschaft eben, weil es einfach noch ganz andere Spielregeln eben im Fußball herrschen, im Fußballzuschauerraum grundsätzlich. Und deswegen ist das eben ein bisschen hinterher auf alle Fälle. Aber das trägt sich natürlich schon ins Stadion, auch rein die Umgangsformen. Die Frauen nehmen sich dann die Rechte raus, etc. Aber wie gesagt, es ist noch mal ein besonderer Fall. Es ist nicht parallel zur Gesellschaft. Aber wie gesagt, abhängig von den Stadien, von den Orten, auch eben, ich denke St. Pauli und 60 kann man sehr schwer vergleichen, sind eben auch noch mal unterschiedlich auch.
Deckt sich das auch so mit deiner Erfahrung, Antje?
Ob sich das verändert oder besser wird mit der Zeit?
Und in welcher Geschwindigkeit?
Also ich sehe auf jeden Fall, wir haben ja eine gesellschaftliche Form von Backlash. Das sehe ich zum Beispiel parallel auch ein bisschen in der Ultrakultur. Also klar gibt es Entwicklungen, zum Beispiel Bibiana Steinhaus ist jetzt Schiedsrichterin. Also die Strukturen öffnen sich langsam auch für Frauen. Aber gleichzeitig werden die Werte, die da teilweise in Fernsehen so gelebt werden, auch immer ein bisschen regressiver und Männlichkeit und Stolz, Ehre, diese ganzen Begrifflichkeiten, so eine Art Verrohung findet da irgendwie auch statt. Das ist mein Eindruck so ein bisschen in den letzten Jahren. Vielleicht ist das auch einfach so eine wellenförmige Sache. Ich weiß es nicht so genau, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, hui, oder vielleicht wird auch mehr darüber geredet oder es ist sichtbar durch Social Media, dass es irgendwie so ganz schön eine krasse Männerbünde und Ahus gibt da auf verschiedenen Ebenen, aber auch eben Hogeza oder gemeinsam stark als huidigen Netzwerke, die sich da sozusagen eher rechtslastig organisieren, sind auf jeden Fall ja auch aktuellere Beispiele so, die auch viel oder aktiv, ja, Männlichkeit, Männlichkeitsbilder ausleben. Ja, ich würde sagen, es ist so eine Parallelentwicklung auch zwischen, was ich gerade gemeint habe, es wird für Frauen schon auch möglicher oder einfacher im Fußballkontext, sich irgendwie sichtbar zu machen, zu sein, zu positionieren, zu engagieren, mancheorts zumindest, aber gleichzeitig gibt es schon auf jeden Fall noch die Werte, die sehr männlich geprägt sind im Fußball weiterhin. Also sowohl was auf Steffi bezogen auch, habe ich auch eher eine langsame Positivdiagnose, dass vielleicht auch die Hoffnung, dass zum Beispiel bei einer Claudia Neumann Moderatorin dann vielleicht doch in den nächsten Jahren bei einer WM dann weniger diskutiert wird, als es jetzt in den letzten Jahren war, also dass sich das irgendwie dann verselbstständig normaler wird, das wird dann nicht bedeuten, dass es keinen Sexismus mehr gibt, aber dass irgendwie langsam die sichtbaren und Führungspositionen vielleicht auch für Frauen mehr zu erreichen sind. Das ist auf jeden Fall vergleichbar zu anderen Führungspositionen in der freien Wirtschaft oder so, dass es da genauso wenig Frauenanteile gibt wie in Vereinen und Verbandsstrukturen.
Ach, noch weniger gibt es im Fußball. Oder noch weniger. Also da eben Präsidentinnen, Geschäftsführerinnen im Fußball, da musst du in Europa wirklich suchen, dass du da jemanden findest, dass deine Frau überhaupt akzeptiert würde. Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr schwierig. Und das ist ja auch bei mir im Verein. Ich bin jetzt Ehrenrätin, aber ich hab da eben, wie viele Frauen sind da in Vorstandspositionen etc. Das ist wirklich, da ist glaube ich 60 jetzt keine Ausnahme, dass das wirklich sehr, sehr wenig ist. Und da ist es schon schwierig. Da muss man schon ein bisschen entsprechend auch die Persönlichkeit haben, dass man das aushält, tatsächlich noch.
Ich bin aber auch bei Sue und der Geschichte, schuldigung Sue, bei der Geschichte von dem kleinen Mädchen, das ist halt dann in 15, 20 Jahren. Eine Frau, die ist jetzt schon aufgewachsen mit weiblichen Vorbildern und das ist selbstverständlicher. Und natürlich gucken wir immer noch eher Männerfußball, aber vielleicht verändert sich der Blick auf Frauenfußball auch. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein wichtiger Faktor, wenn wir über Fußball reden, dass wir nicht nur über Männerfußball sprechen usw. Dann würde ich den Beiden direkt an zupassen, die jetzt gerade was sagen wollte.
Das ist eigentlich auch immer so die ersten Personen, die irgendwas machen. Es wird ja auch viel darüber diskutiert. Der erste schwule Spieler, der sich outet, der ist dann halt erstmal der schwule Mensch und dann irgendwann Fußballer. Bei Frauen im Fußball ist es halt auch immer so, dass sie dann für alle Frauen erstmal stehen. Das ist natürlich auch so eine Verantwortung, wo man sich zweimal überlegt, so mache ich das jetzt. Dann, egal was ich sage, es wird halt auf alle Frauen gemünzt und sobald es dann quasi mehr davon gibt, wie auch bei Claudia Manleumann, wenn es jetzt zehn weibliche Kommentatoren gibt, dann wird da vielleicht irgendwann genauso diskutiert über Qualitäten oder sonst was und halt nicht immer, dass sie schlecht ist, weil sie eine Frau ist oder so. Also da denke ich mal, das wird sich schon so ein bisschen ändern, wobei ich vorhin noch einhaken wollte, das war ja auch schon mal anders. Also jetzt so in den 20er-, 30er-Jahren oder so, also natürlich auch durch Krieg bedingt in England, gab es in jeder großen Stadt irgendwie eine Frauenmannschaft und dagegen Zehntausende hin. Und dann, wie das bei vielen anderen Dingen ist, wurde das dann von Männern quasi aus Gründen der Physis oder sonst was, wie wir es ja auch vom Autofahren kennen, sonst was, also dass dann das schlecht für die Gesundheit von Frauen sein soll und so weiter, das quasi wieder zurückerobert. Und also das weibliche da wieder so ein bisschen unterdrückt. Und das sind ja immer so Wellenbewegungen. Und zu dem, was Antje sagte, mit dem Ton, der härter wird, das ist, glaube ich, auch so dieses Typische, das wird man ja nochmal sagen dürfen. Also dass das einfach allgemein momentan einfach so dieser populistische Stil und dass Frauen auf was weiß ich oder in Bayern mit der CSU und dass dann irgendwie die Frauen zu Hause Geld bekommen, wenn sie da die Kinder betreuen. Und es gibt ja viele so Bereiche, wo so die eigentlich schon erreichte Dinge so wieder so ein bisschen zurückgeschraubt werden, habe ich das Gefühl momentan. Also da würde ich den Fußball gar nicht von freisprechen. Aber es ist natürlich noch eine Domäne, wo die Männer einfach das Gefühl haben, die Frauen nehmen ihnen was weg, wenn sie jetzt auch da, also früher konnten sie machen, was sie wollten, und jetzt müssen sie sich ja irgendwie benehmen. Also das ist ja auch immer so, wenn man in so eine Männerrunde reinkommt, oh, jetzt müssen wir uns aber anders unterhalten. Oder dann werden über die Herrenwitze dann nochmal Witze gemacht. Und da braucht man dann halt schon so ein bisschen dickes Fell, um das so an sich abprallen zu lassen oder halt auch mal was dagegen zu sagen. Und also auch Bibiana Steinhaus ist da ja auch ein schönes Beispiel. Also wenn du denkst, dass das Männersport dann schlimm ist, also da will ich jetzt nicht sagen, was in meinem Verein da teilweise fällt, wenn sie pfeift, obwohl sie unsere Aufstiegs-Bibi ist. Also das ist schon... Aufstiegs-Bibi? Ja, sie hat unser Aufstiegs-Spiel gefilmt. Also einfach so, bei uns sind Stein im Brett und... Ja, aber das Übliche dann, was weiß ich, dann kommt halt Fadze, sonst was, blaa, anstatt halt... Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht. Also Schiris beleidigt man ja immer, aber... Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Ja, aber mit Frauen wird schon quasi kritisierend anders umgegangen. Das ist quasi das, was ich auch im Rasenfunk sehen kann, wo ich ja versuche, auch viele Frauen hinter die Mikrofone zu bekommen, was gar nicht so einfach ist aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen. Aber was mir immer schon aufgefallen ist, sogar bei den Rasenfunk-Hörern und Hörern, wo ich sagen würde, die haben noch einen anderen Diskussionsstil als weite andere Teile des Internets, werden Frauen auf eine andere Art und Weise kritisiert, und zwar pauschaler. Also mir hat ihre Einschätzung zum Werder-Spiel nicht gefallen, deswegen schreibe ich jetzt nicht immer im Kommentar, ich fand, dass sie dabei Werder irgendwie, das habe ich anders gesehen, sondern ich schreibe, die hatte ja echt mal keine Ahnung von Taktik, bitte nie wieder einladen. Solche Kommentare gab es noch nie bei einem Mann. Das ist unglaublich.
Da kannst du ja noch froh sein, dass das ein Podcast ist und dass es nicht irgendwie ein Live-Mitschnitt ist mit Videoaufnahme, weil ich glaube, dann die Kommentare noch mal anders werden, weil Optik auf jeden Fall eine Rolle spielt. Ob es jetzt bei Bibiana Steinhaus ist, oder meinetwegen auch bei Claudia Neumann oder sonst wo. Also, was ihr gerade schon gesagt habt, es wird auf jeden Fall aufs Geschlecht reduziert und geschlechtsspezifische Abwertungen, es wird das Fachwissen öfter mal in Frage gestellt und dann im Zweifelsfall noch einfach mal, einfach nur was zur Optik gesagt. Also, anstatt zu sagen, okay, die konnte übrigens auch was zum Thema Fußball sagen oder hat gut gespielt oder sonstiges so.
Ja, das ist ein ganz anderes Niveau. Also, wir haben es auch gemerkt bei uns eben, wo eben auch die Ulla auf unserer Vereinsveranstaltung einen Antrag gestellt hatte und auf so einer dämlichen Website von irgendwie so einem trotteligen Blogger die Kommentare.
Ich weiß genau, welchen du meinst.
Und das ist wirklich unterirdisch, was da für Kommentare kommen. Du weißt genau, das würden die nie machen, wenn das ein Mann wäre. Also so auf diesem Niveau einfach auch ein sowas. Also wirklich so niveolos und so aufs Äußerliche reduziert. Das ist schon heftig. Also da merkt man dann schon nochmal den Unterschied auch.
Ja, als Frau muss man einfach zehnmal besser sein, als es jeder Mann sein müsste, um überhaupt akzeptiert zu werden. Also es ist schon irgendwie so.
Ja, du darfst dir keine normalen Fehler eben erlauben. Eben dann eben sei es jetzt in der Optik oder im Auftreten. Das wird dann sofort, da bist du sofort angegriffen.
Dann auf Podcast bezogen oder eh Medienpräsenz ja auch nochmal das Ding, dass glaube ich, sich Frauen auch vielleicht weniger trauen und sagen, ach, ich habe ja eh keine Ahnung oder Sachverstand. Also wenn du jetzt von Rasenfunk auch sagst, ich habe irgendwie Probleme, Frauen zu finden, selbst wenn du sagen willst, ich suche jetzt explizit Frauen und mache mal einen großen Post oder eine Kampagne oder so, würden sich wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch weniger Frauen melden, weil sie sich das nicht zutrauen.
Das ist tatsächlich genau die Erfahrung, die ich mache. Also zum einen ist es so, dass es immer noch mehr Männer als Frauen gibt. Das ist so, also ich habe hier in meiner Gästedatenbank, da kann ich gerade live nachgucken, da habe ich drin 225 Männer, noch nicht alle davon waren zu hören, aber sind schon auf meinem Radar. Und dagegen nur 60 Frauen. Auf 60? Ja, für diese 60 Frauen muss ich dann schon in einer Art und Weise durch soziale Netzwerke scrollen, die mir selbst manchmal ein bisschen creepy vorkommen, weil ich bei jedem weiblichen Twitterer sofort denke, die könnte ich ja vielleicht mal einladen und dann nachlese, was die so über ihren Verein geschrieben haben. Und dann ist aber die Erfahrung, die ich tatsächlich auch mache, wenn ich Absagen bekomme für den Rasenfunk, dann in überwiegender Mehrheit von Frauen, weil die Anfrage läuft immer so, hier, ich hätte dich gerne mal mit dabei, wir reden über deinen Verein und auch über alle anderen Spieler, hättest du da Lust drauf, hier kannst du mal eine Folge hören. Und bei Männern ist die Reaktion, wir reden über alle Vereine, ja, gar kein Problem. Und bei Frauen ist die Reaktion ganz oft, bei meinem Verein fühle ich mich relativ sicher, aber ich würde eigentlich ungern über einen anderen Verein reden, weil da bin ich nicht tief genug drin. Und manchmal stimmt das vielleicht auch, manchmal ist es aber auch, also manchmal weiß ich es, weil manche Leute habe ich auch sehr hartnäckig überzeugt, da habe ich dann im Nachhinein auch festgestellt, das war einfach Quatsch, die waren genauso tief drin. Und das ist quasi kein Zufall, das ist im Rasenfunk Royal, also in dem, wo ich immer einen Gast für einen Verein habe und auf die Hinrunde oder auf die ganze Saison zurückblicke, da fällt es mir viel leichter, Frauen zu kriegen. Da bin ich immer so bei sieben bis acht Frauen bei 18 Vereinen, was okay ist. Immer noch nicht 50 Prozent, aber da kommen wir schon noch irgendwie hin. Aber für diese Folgen, wo du quasi über alle Spiele reden musst, das ist immer genau das, wo ich die Absagen kriege. Und das ist ganz interessant. Und Männer sagen da immer, ja easy, ich gucke die Sportschau. Und dann sage ich, ja, also wenn du noch mehr gucken kannst, wäre es auch nicht schlecht. Kannst auch gerne die Sportschau gucken, aber guck mal, ob dir noch mehr über den Weg läuft. Und das ist echt schon nochmal ein Unterschied.
Aber es ist gut, dass du da dran bleibst, finde ich. Ich habe zum Beispiel die Saisonvorschau-Schlusskonferenz da, Bundesliga-Vorschau quasi gehört, und da war ja auch eine Frau mit dabei. Ich bin super krass gefreut einfach. Also duft das jetzt klingt und manche werden sagen, beschwer dich mal nicht, aber es macht schon einen Unterschied auch gerade für eine Frau im Fußball, wenn man dann auch irgendwie andere Frauen mal hört und die Sachverstand haben und nicht immer nur Männer. Also natürlich kein Problem mit Männern und die haben auch auf jeden Fall Ahnung und so, aber es macht einen Unterschied sozusagen, ob eine Frau auch mal damit am Start ist oder nicht. Und es freut mich persönlich dann auch, wie in dem Fall ziemlich doll.
Ja, man sagt auch schwerer nein. Also zum Beispiel die Kristall von Augsburg hatte auch gesagt für einen Podcast vor dem Spiel und ich hatte zwei Tage vorher gesagt, ich habe echt gar keine Zeit sonst was und ich mache jetzt erst mal gar nichts wegen Tastic Females. Und als sie mich dann fragte, dachte ich, naja, vielleicht kannst du es noch irgendwie reinkwetschen. Also man möchte sich dann auch so ein bisschen gegenseitig unterstützen. Also das merkt man schon. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch einfach so immer noch ein bisschen Erziehungssache sonst was, dass Frauen sich ständig, also das merkt mich auch an mir selber, dass man sich ständig hinterfragt und dann irgendwie so mal einfach so, jojo und man selber überlegt dann so tausendmal ja, aber hast du in dem Bereich jetzt die Erfahrung oder auch bei Vorstellungsgesprächen sonst was? Also man fängt dann mit den eigenen Schwächen an und denkt sich dann hinterher so, was soll der Scheiß eigentlich? Also da müssen wir auch einfach alle an uns selber arbeiten. Also im Prinzip hat ja keiner von allem Ahnung. Also man muss es halt nur gut überspielen können.
Aber wobei im Fußball ist halt wirklich das Thema, dass du da halt echt auf jede Schwäche, die du hast, oder jeden kleinen Fehler, da wird dann eben dann, eben wenn es ist halt wirklich reingegrätscht auch und da, da ist dann die Befürchtung eben schon da, wo du eben sagst, okay, kann ich das wirklich, bin ich da so souverän, dass ich da keinen Punkt gebe für die Leute? Oder eben man muss halt dann wirklich ein wahnsinniges Selbstbewusstsein auch haben, dass man sagt, okay, mir ist das wurscht, was die sagen irgendwie, da kommen die Kommentare und ich stehe da drüber. Also das ist dann im Fußballbereich schon nochmal, ja.
Ja, ist ja auch das Gleiche, wenn man irgendwie Sexismus anspricht, dann weiß man genau, also die ganzen kurten Dinge, also man kann sich dann vorher schon ausrichten, wozu was sagt, wer dann wieder welche Kommentare bringen wird. Also fand ich auch ganz faszinierend, wir sind in der Kurve umgezogen und hatten dann so ein Gespräch mit den Leuten, die da vorher standen und was da zum Teil für Fragen kam, da dachte ich mir wirklich, also lebst du im letzten Jahrhundert oder? Aber das ist dann so die Realität, wie Antja auch schon erwähnte, wenn man aus der eigenen Bubble so ein bisschen rauskommt oder, also ganz extrem ist ja auch, wenn man mal als Frau allein ins Stadion geht oder so. Was man da erlebt, das ist echt unglaublich. Also da muss man schon vorher so ein bisschen Kampfsport trainieren. Das ist dann echt, also.
Aber was müsste sich denn alles verändern? Das ist klar, das wird jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen alles toll werden, weil die Definition von toll wahrscheinlich auch in dieser Runde ganz anders sind, als wenn wir 100 Leute in der Fußgängerzone fragen. Aber was wären denn so Schritte, die sich tun müssten, wenn wir jetzt mal beim Stadionbesuch zum Beispiel anfangen? Ich hatte das mal, ich stehe normalerweise immer mit meiner Gruppe in der Kurve und da sind wir uns eh alle einig und da finden wir Rassismuskacke und so weiter und so fort. Und dann stand ich mal in der Nordkurve und wir haben gespielt mit Bayern gegen Gladbach, genau da hat Moda Huth damals noch gespielt, und da hat ein Typ hinter mir in einer Penetrance, immer wenn er am Ball war, geschrofen, ich glaube irgendwie, naja es war was Rassistisches in jedem Fall. Und da war ich zum ersten Mal seit Ewigkeiten wieder in der Situation, dass ich jetzt überlegen musste, wie verhalte ich mich jetzt? Ich muss was tun, andererseits ist der Typ wahnsinnig dicht und gefühlt wog der 200 Kilo, und ich bin halt ich. Und dann habe ich aber dann irgendwann gedacht, nee, aber ich kann jetzt auch nicht, und alle anderen haben nichts gesagt um mich auszuholen. Das hat mich wahnsinnig wütend gemacht, dann dachte ich mir, okay gut, ich kann jetzt nicht immer sagen, ich bin dagegen und dann kann ich nichts tun. Dann habe ich mich dann umgedreht und gesagt, kannst du mal aufhören immer so eine Scheiße zu labern? Und sagen wir so, es war kein fruchtbarer Dialog, aber er hat nicht mehr bei jedem Ball Kontakt geschrien und vor allem habe ich gesehen, dass außenrum so zwei, drei haben sich gedacht, cool, dass du es gemacht hast. Aber quasi das jetzt, ein bisschen zu lange Anekdote, ich wollte es mich nicht selbst loben, sondern als Ausgangspunkt für die Frage, was müsste sich denn beim Stadionbesuch verändern, dass sich das peu à peu verbessert und dass jemand wie du nicht mehr sagen muss, ich brauche eine Nahkampferfahrung, um ins Alleine in den Stadion zu gehen.
Ja, also das war jetzt auch so ein bisschen übertrieben dargestellt. Also es kommt halt auch immer drauf an, ob man halt den Mund aufmacht oder nicht. Also das ist ja auch immer so ein, man kann ja auch Dinge überhören. Also mache ich auch manchmal, wenn ich einen schlechten Tag habe, sonst was, dann denke ich auch, komm, gehst jetzt einfach vorbei und hältst mal deine Klappe, ist schon spät, du kommst zu spät, sonst was, wie man sich das dann schön redet, genau wie du das sagst. Aber als Frau hat man das selbst in der Bezugsgruppe eigentlich jedes Spiel, dass irgendwelche Leute dann ein paar Reihen hinter was brüllen und wo man sich halt dann immer überlegt, macht man was, macht man nicht. Und da ist es auch einfach, man braucht auch so ein bisschen den Support von anderen Leuten, weil es einfach ein Unterschied ist, ob sich eine Frau umdreht oder zum Beispiel, ob sich zehn Frauen umdrehen. Das ist übrigens ein super Effekt, der immer wirkt, weil A, sehen die dann, wie viele Frauen sind denn hier und realisieren vielleicht so, was habe ich da gerade gesagt. Am besten finde ich es dann, wenn die Freundin von dem Kerl anfängt, ihn zu verteidigen, dass er gerade irgendwie sexistisch, rassistisch oder sonst was, wo ich dann noch mietender auf die Frau werde als als auf den Typen oder so. Aber eigentlich wie überall in der Gesellschaft. Man muss halt für seine Ideale einstehen, den Mund aufmachen und wenn der Erste das tut, dann folgen andere nach. Und also manchmal kann man dann so quasi die ganze Kurve umstimmen und manchmal muss man halt irgendwann laufen gehen. Also das kommt dann immer auf das Verhältnis an der Menschen. Also ich weiß nicht, wie ist denn das bei euch so?
Ja, im Grunde genommen, also ich finde es eben schon wichtig, das dann anzusprechen. Deswegen fand ich die Geschichte jetzt gar nicht so lang, die du erzählt hast, Max, eben weil es dann den anderen auch so geht. Die sind ein bisschen auch verunsichert und das ist häufig so der Gedanke bei vielen, bin ich jetzt da falsch? Bin ich jetzt da übertrieben? Sollte ich was sagen? Die sind die anderen und wenn es ausgesprochen wird, dann eben, dann ist der Konsens okay. Ich bin richtig und eben der ist falsch und ja, und das bleibt nicht so im Raum stehen. Und insofern ist sowas schon wichtig, auch für alle festzustellen, wo sind hier die Normen, wo sind hier die Regeln. So wenn man so das alles durchgehen lässt, so einen Typen eben mit seinen rassistischen Rufen, dann werden da einfach die Regeln durch den eben dann auch mitbestimmt. Wenn man aber was dagegen sagt und alle schnicken dann eben dann dazu, dann ist da die Grenze gesetzt. Insofern ist sowas wirklich wichtig auch zu sagen. In der Art und Weise, die hängt dann natürlich von der Person auch ab. Ob er jetzt ein bisschen grober wird, ein bisschen deutlicher, ob man das ein bisschen scherzhafter macht. Also mache ich dann je nachdem, wenn es besoffene junge Typen sind und die dann hey schwule Sau schreien, dann ach Kinder, es geht eben, was ist denn schwul, dann kann man so anders dann mit denen reden. Oder einfach mal einfach auch darauf hinweisen, weil vielen ist das auch gar nicht bewusst, wie sie reden, je nachdem, was das für Personen sind. Da muss man jetzt nicht Riesendiskussionen über Sexismus starten, das macht im Starten sowieso keinen Sinn, aber eben einfach mal darauf aufmerksam machen. Das ist schon mal das Erste einfach. Und eben auch so umgangsformen, allein schon. Und eben das auch anderen erzählen, weil dem meisten ist das gar nicht so bewusst, wie da der Umgangston eben auch ist. Ich finde eben sowieso die Ausstellung oder auch sämtliche Berichte von Frauen einfach ganz wichtig, weil das vielen Männern auch gar nicht bewusst ist.
Ich glaube, es gibt da auch verschiedene Strategien einfach. Eine Strategie ist zum Beispiel auch nicht, diese Wörter wie Feminismus oder Sexismus in den Mund zu nehmen. Weil ich glaube, bei vielen schlackern dann die Ohren. Oder lilanes Tuch oder so. Ich finde, man muss jetzt nicht Leute verschonen, aber man kann auch versuchen, das zu umschreiben und sagen, hey, irgendwie gerade bist du mir gegenüber ungerecht oder Frauen gegenüber ungerecht. Oder das ist irgendwie, warum sind Frauen und Männer denn nicht gleich? Oder man kann verschiedenste Argumentationen wählen, ohne da sozusagen diese politische Crack des Keules rauszuholen. Das ist so ein Punkt. Ich finde auch immer wichtig, vielleicht Dinge, auch wenn sie jetzt so wie im Stadion bei dir jetzt total nerven, nicht sofort zu regeln. Also kommt drauf an, wie belastender man auch ist in der Situation. Aber gerade in den eigenen Reihen habe ich häufiger mal das Ding, dass ich dann in dem Moment gar nicht sehe, dass es Sinn macht, da irgendwie zu intervenieren, sondern mir dann eine ruhige Minute suche oder nach dem Spiel oder so. Dann fühlen sich die Leute auch wesentlich weniger angegriffen, wenn man das einmal noch in Ruhe macht und danach. Natürlich bei manchen Sachen, da gibt es No-Goes, da muss man auch reagieren. Aber da habe ich auch manchmal so das Ding, ich bin halt auch, wie Sue das eben angesprochen hat, ich bin auch einfach manchmal müde. Ich mache so viele Erfahrungen einfach, wenn ich auf der Straße lang gehe, schon, wie ich angeguckt werde, wie ich angesprochen werde. Und dann auch noch im Stadion bei manchen Sachen, da bin ich einfach absolut nicht bereit, diejenige zu sein, die dann interveniert. Und da bin ich dann halt auch auf meine Freundinnen und Freunde angewiesen und gerade auf meine männlichen Kollegen, die dann vielleicht auch mal was sagen wollen, können, sollten. Es gibt verschiedene Strategien, wer und wie und wann vielleicht dann auch.
Ja auch so ein Fänkgesang eben mit so, Fußball ist ein Männersport oder eben mit anderen Sachen. Das macht jetzt keinen Sinn, da hinzugehen und zum Kapo, weil bist du da, ist es eh schon vorbei oder sowas eben. Aber das dann im Nachhinein einfach mal thematisieren und eben auf eine ruhige Art und nicht eben nicht mit dem Zeigefinger, sondern einfach so, hey, pass mal auf und genau. Und dann kann man das besprechen oder eben auch aufs Femprojekt zugehen, dass die das thematisieren, eben je nachdem. Also, wird dies einfach so sprechen und genau, einfach so Sachen offen. Ja, und eben bei Sexismus ist es nochmal kritischer als jetzt eben Rassismus, weil da sofort sehr stachelig reagiert wird, wie die Antje eben auch gesagt hat. Sobald das Wort Sexismus fällt, dann so, eh, so, ah, du, Feministin, lass mich in Ruhe, etc. Sondern eben da muss man wirklich sehr sachte behutsam, sag ich mal, vorgehen, um da mit kleinen Schritten, um da überhaupt was zu erreichen.
Da besteht eben noch nicht dieser Konsens. Also Rassismus ist halt gesellschaftlich jetzt anerkannt. Okay, auf den Laute machen ist No-Go. Aber halt wuren so einen Fotze, keine Ahnung was, das ist halt Umgangssprache. Und da regen sich dann wieder die Weiber auf und heulen rum. Also, das ist schon noch ein Unterschied.
Obwohl ich mich auch rausnehme, in Situationen auch vehement oder vielleicht auch einfach mal ziemlich krass zu reagieren. Natürlich macht es vielleicht irgendwie im Endeffekt mehr Sinn, das in einem ruhigen Moment zu sagen. Und ich habe auch eine streitschlechteren Ausbildung, aber vielleicht habe ich trotzdem auch eine Kampfsportausbildung.
Wer kommt schon auf eine Ausbildung zurückgreifen, die er mit elf Jahren gemacht hat?
Genau, eigentlich.
Ja, aber auch was ich ganz witzig finde, oder was ich mir gerade überlegt habe, auch neulich wieder so ein Wahnsinns-T-Shirt im Facebook gepostet. Tolles T-Shirt, das ist alles, was ich brauchte. Dann ist halt ein Bierkrug, das sechziger Wappen, und in der Mitte halt eben Titten. Ja, ganz genau, richtig. Das kannte ich schon, habe ich schon mal gesehen. Wir haben uns damals schon gelacht und ich so, hallo, ich hätte gern das T-Shirt mit einem Schwanz statt mit Titten. Das hat jetzt wieder jemand gepostet in so einem 60 München, in einer offenen Gruppe. Tolles T-Shirt. Da habe ich mir gedacht, was sage ich jetzt irgendwie dazu? Weil eigentlich sollte es da auch nicht sein, weil die setzen sich ja gegen Sexismus und gegen Diskriminierung jeglicher Art an in der Gruppe. Aber genau, dann habe ich halt gesagt, eben den Kommentar gibt es das T-Shirt auch mit Schwanz statt Titten. Eben auf so eine Art. Und da habe ich mir überlegt, sollte ich mir das T-Shirt bestellen? Und das nächste Mal, wenn ich zum Thema Sexismus irgendwo bin, sollte ich das einfach anziehen? Und das sind ja dann auch so die Leute einfach so, wie sagt man denn dann? Das ist ja auch so eine Stilform irgendwie so damit.
Ein bisschen entwaffnend.
Verwirrten eben auch, ganz genau.
Konfrontationstherapie. Ja, finde ich auch, dass das eigentlich immer gut wirkt.
Ja, wenn ich so ein Titten-T-Shirt an habe, ich finde das schon.
Ja, die Augsburger hatten das Titten-T-Shirt mit Augsburger Jungs drauf. Da meinte ich auch so, ey, coole Titten und sonst was. So verwirrte Blicke. Text-Bildschere war dann schon wieder zu schwierig, das kam nicht mehr an.
Oder einen Fußball-Ficken-Feminismus-Aufkleber machen, wie wir das von Finn gemacht haben, und da ein bisschen auf Konfrontation gehen.
Den kann man auch super auf irgendwelche Kunden-Dinger kleben. Hab ich auch schon häufiger gemacht.
Über die entsprechenden Aufnäher dann, stark.
Ja, genau, über diesen Aufnehmer, wo Bayern-Fans Schweine ficken oder sowas.
Ja, lasst uns doch einfach über Tierhaltung sprechen. Wie wichtig sind denn da eurer Meinung nach die Medien? Wir haben es jetzt vorhin schon mal angesprochen, Claudia Neumann. Mir geht es jetzt gar nicht. Also es ist ja klar, dass die sichtbaren Frauen eine große Bedeutung haben. Das ist logisch. Das ist, finde ich, eine rhetorische Frage. Aber jetzt die Medienhäuser. Zum Beispiel könnten ja gerade die öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkanstalten, die ja in der Theorie schon auch einen gewissen Auftrag eigentlich hätten, die könnten doch eigentlich auch mal sagen, wir machen jetzt drei Frauen zu Kommentatorinnen. Oder wir achten ganz speziell darauf, dass wir nicht vier Männer haben, die WM-Experten sind, sondern wenigstens eine, vielleicht auch zwei Frauen, dass sich die Kritik dann so ein bisschen zerschellt oder verteilt.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig, definitiv.
Aber könnt ihr euch erklären, warum das nicht so ist? Also das erste Argument ist ja immer, es gibt nicht so viele Frauen. Das ist Quatsch. Also dann würde ich nicht 60 Frauen bei mir haben.
Den Intendanten an, also wo sind da die Frauen?
Ja, das ist es vielleicht. Aber das wäre doch eigentlich schon das wichtigste Feld. Oder würdet ihr sagen, in den Vereinen ist es noch wichtiger, Frauen zu haben, sichtbar zu haben?
In allen Bereichen im Grunde genommen. Fernsehen, ganz wichtig auf alle Fälle. Wie vorhin schon gesagt wurde, wenn es nicht eine Kommentatorin ist, sondern wenn es zehn Kommentatoren sind, irgendwann hört sich das dann auch auf. Dann verteilt sich das, dann wird das nicht so fokussiert. Da ist es ganz wichtig, auf alle Fälle. Warum das nicht so ist, das liegt natürlich wirklich an diesen vergrößteten Strukturen in diesen Fernsehstationen.
Aber auch an die Frauen, die es gibt, dargestellt werden.
Genau, weil man die Zielgruppen wirklich anspricht und dann vielleicht auch mit der Werbung etc. Da sind dann die Stationen eben auch dann gefragt. In der Pause kommt immer nur Bierwerbung etc.
Na ja, und Parship.
Das ist nur Single-Management. Also das ist schon wichtig. Aber auch in den Vereinen ist es meines Erachtens auch wichtig, eben in Fanshops etc., dass man schaut, dass da entsprechende Angebote für Männer und für Frauen gleichermaßen gelten. Dass eben nicht nur, bin ich wieder bei meinem Lieblings 60er Beispiel, eben auch ein Wippbesuch für den Herren, die Frauen können ja mitgehen. Es gibt den Ladies Day in der Allianz Arena. Während die Männer sich beim Biertrinken über ein Fußballspiel unterhalten, sind die Frauen im Wellnessbereich und gönnen sich eine Handmassage. Solche Sachen eben, ja, ganz, ganz wichtig auch. Oder eben am Muttertag, was macht man zur Halbzeit? Ja, Wäsche aufhängen, Frauen werden die schnellste Wäsche aufhängt. Wahnsinnsaktionen irgendwie dann eben auch. Ja, Wahnsinn, also echt, wo man sich nur am Kopf langt. Das sind ganz, ganz wichtige Sachen eben auch, die auf allen Ebenen ablaufen müssen.
Aber bei sowas ist auch die Reaktion enorm wichtig. Da ist es dann auch einfach wichtig, dass man dem Verein sagt, das ist scheiße, was jeder macht, und das könnt ihr nicht nochmal machen. Ich glaube, jeder Verein, wir hatten dann auch mal so irgendwie pinke Sachen und sonst was. Da gab es dann halt immer einen Shitstorm. Inzwischen fragen sie dann auch mal. Aber allein dieses Jahr gab es bei uns auch wieder so ein Skandälchen, wo man dann auch ganz massiv als Frauen Präsenz zeigen musste. Wir haben jetzt zum ersten Mal wieder eine Aufsichtsrätin. Ansonsten sind es bei uns halt alles nur Männer. Da fehlt es dann einfach an so viel Verständnis an allen Ecken und Enden, dass man sich dann zum Teil wieder wie im letzten Jahrhundert fühlt. Das sind Leute, die es eigentlich gut machen wollen. Wo schon quasi der Wille da ist, aber das dann irgendwie nie zu Ende gedacht wird. Da haben wir jetzt einige Sachen angestoßen. Da wurde auch gut reagiert. Wir haben ja von euch quasi unseren Vorstandsvorsitzenden bekommen. Da danke ich euch auch für. Er wird niemals mehr irgendwas mit einem Investor machen. Als geläuterter Mensch quasi. Super.
Warum ist denn Bier?
Einer musste das Feuer gehen.
Ja, da setzt er sich jetzt auch öffentlich für ein. Ich muss immer an dich denken, wenn er irgendwas dagegen sagt. Aber das sind auch persönliche Erfahrungen. Jetzt hat er auch so ein Aha-Erlebnis, was weibliche Fans gibt. Das hat bei ihm im Kopf auch ganz viel bewegt. Jetzt ist er damit auch zur DFL gegangen und hat da ganz tolle Sachen gesagt. Weil er wirklich ein Verständnis eingesetzt hat. Ich glaube, wenn man einzelne Personen das Bewusstsein verändert, dann werden die wieder andere verändern und das anstoßen. Wie du auch sagt, man muss halt mit den Leuten reden. Die Arbeit hört nie auf. Irgendeiner muss das ja tun.
Wenn wir jetzt über Frauen in Führungspositionen im Verein sprechen, es ist ja alles erklärbar, warum das so männerlastig ist. Es sind Männerstrukturen. Sowohl in den Redaktionen, so erklärt sich sehr gut, warum Journalistinnen häufig nur die hübschen Mikrofonhalterungen sein dürfen und höchstens mal so eine On-Field-Frage stellen, aber nie diejenige ist, die jetzt erklärt, warum da jemand sich nicht aus dem Deckungsschatten gelöst hat. Das dürfen halt dann immer die Männer machen. Also das kann man sich gut erklären. Man kann sich auch erklären, warum in den Vereinen so viele Männer sitzen. Jetzt gibt es das Mittel der Quote. Ich weiß, dass das ein riesiges Thema ist, aber wie steht ihr drei dazu? Steffi, du darfst mal anfangen. Müsste man darüber nachdenken?
Das ist ein ganz schwieriges Thema. Das ist ja generell auch ein schwieriges Thema. Ich habe tatsächlich mir überlegt vor unserer letzten Mitgliederversammlung, ob ich den Antrag stelle, dass man da eine gewisse Quote einfüllt. Das führt eben jetzt im EV bei uns für die Ämter, weil ich es wirklich sehr, sehr schade finde, dass so wenig Frauen eben im Verwaltungsratpräsidium, dass man sagt, okay, wenigstens eine Frau eben da vertreten ist. Ich habe es mir tatsächlich überlegt, bin da generell auch mit den Quotenregelungen eher ein bisschen skeptisch, wobei eben manchmal ist es einfach auch notwendig, um da einfach was auch in Gang zu setzen. Ich habe mich dann dagegen entschieden, weil ich mir dachte, das ist kontraktproduktiv. Das wird nur gegen wer hervorrufen.
Aber muss man nicht manchmal die verschlossene Tür mit der Brechstange erst ein bisschen aufhebeln?
Ja, aber ich denke immer, in dem Bereich wäre es so gewesen, dass der Antrag von vorne ran von den Fans abgelehnt oder Mitgliedern abgelehnt worden wäre. Das habe ich mir eben gedacht. Und dann geht der Schuss nach hinten los. Deswegen habe ich mich dagegen entschieden, habe auch mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen. Also das wird nicht klappen, das wird nicht klappen in dem Verein. Eben überlege ich jetzt gerade in der KGAA, ob das eine Möglichkeit ist. Eine Möglichkeit wäre bei uns, sehe ich das überhaupt nicht, in anderen Vereinen vielleicht da. Ich finde es nicht verkehrt, wenn da einfach mehr ist. Dann auch für die Fans eben vom Umgang her, dass da eben Frauen genauso arbeiten. Das finde ich schon.
Antje, wie stehst du dazu?
Na, es gibt auf jeden Fall Gegenargumente. Und auch gerade dieses beliebte, sollen halt doch nur Qualifizierte dahin kommen und nicht Leute, die dann gewählt werden, weil sie ein bestimmtes Geschlecht haben. Aber ich sehe es auf jeden Fall auch so, dass es teilweise dann doch nur die einzige Möglichkeit ist und so viel Vetternwirtschaft oder Brotherhood-Strukturen da am Start sind. Dass es ohne eine Quote vielleicht doch nicht funktioniert. Man kann es auch einfach mal versuchen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass dann die Qualität sinken würde, sondern vielleicht einfach eher nochmal andere Leute auf dem Schirm sind und sich nicht gegenseitig die Posten und Positionen zugeschoben werden. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das gerade auf repräsentativer Ebene, DFL, DFB, was auch immer, UEFA, FIFA, dafür vielleicht auch nochmal mehr Sinn machen würde und dann vielleicht runter zu den Vereinen und den verschiedenen kleineren Playern in dem ganzen System. Aber ja, definitiv, wie gesagt, also ich bin da auf jeden Fall pro, weil für mich die Positivargumente auf jeden Fall überwiegen gegenüber den Negativen und sich vielleicht sonst auch echt schleppend oder bis gar nicht Situationen und Dinge ändern werden.
Also so im persönlichen Bereich denke ich auch immer, das ist so, als ob man es nicht alleine schaffen würde. Aber wenn man sich die Auswirkungen in der Wirtschaft und überall anguckt, bin ich eigentlich auch dafür, also gerade auch so in Bereichen zum Beispiel, wir haben keine weibliche Fanbetreuerin. Wir haben keinen, das wurde nach dem Gladbach-Vorfall auch diskutiert. Es gibt keine Ansprechpartnerinnen.
Also du meinst jetzt, die sexuelle Nötigung war es in einem Fanzug oder worauf?
Vergewaltigung, ja, glaube ich.
Ich wusste nicht, ob es bewiesen war, deswegen wollte ich jetzt nicht.
Um da aber einzuhaken, ja auch irgendwie sozusagen keine offiziellen Ansprechpartnerinnen bei solchen Fällen. Es gibt keine Strategien, keine Pläne, wie man mit sowas umgeht. Das kann natürlich auch nochmal, sollte auch am besten nicht von den Fans kommen müssen, sondern vom Verein oder von den Verbandsstrukturen schon vorgegeben werden. Aber wie gesagt, es muss halt oft leider erst von den Fans sowas angestoßen werden.
Also ist auch angestoßen worden und da kommt jetzt auch was. Aber um nochmal auf die Quote zurückzukommen, also ich glaube auch, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht anders möglich ist und wenn man dann sieht, dass es gut ist, kann man sie auch wieder abschaffen. Aber ich glaube zumindest, man sollte so ein Mindeststandard oder so, das klingt zwar lächerlich, aber dass es eine Frau gibt, aber dann eine Frau alleine ist halt auch immer ein bisschen schwierig. Also deswegen ist das vielleicht dann ganz gut, dass man mal so zwei, drei hat und es dann halt einfacher wird. Also ich glaube auch, sobald es so ein paar gab, dann wird es ja auch immer einfacher. Also wenn die Leute merken, okay, es ist nicht der Weltuntergang, wenn da eine Frau steht, dann wird es die nächste Frau auch leichter haben. Aber ich denke auch, dass das von den Verbänden runtergehen muss und ich weiß gar nicht, also viele Vereine sind jetzt auch Wirtschaftsunternehmen, müssten da nicht sowieso theoretisch Quoten greifen. Also wir sind ja ein eingetragener Verein, aber es gibt ja viele Aktiengesellschaften und sonst was. Also da gibt es doch eine Quote, oder?
Aber wie wäre es denn auch, also wenn wir jetzt schon davon sprechen, dass ja viele Dinge von Fans angestoßen werden müssen, sollte es denn bei Positionen, die es unter Fans gibt, denn da vielleicht eine Quote geben. Eine von vier Kapos ist weiblich. Ich weiß, dass das jetzt eine krasse Forderung ist, aber allein dass diese Forderung sich schon beim Aussprechen krass anfühlt, zeigt ja, wie notwendig sie vielleicht auch ist, oder?
Ja, für mich sind Fan-Strukturen aber noch mal selbst organisiert und keine offiziellen Gremien zum Beispiel.
Ja klar, aber die könnten ja auch selbst organisiert dann sagen, wir nehmen uns das jetzt vor. Das, also es sind ja hierarchische Strukturen und die könnten sich das ja, also das wird jetzt immer nur jede Fanszene für sich selbst sich vornehmen können, aber könnte das nicht auch ein Weg sein?
Hm, ich finde, dass da eben da, da kam halt kein Einfluss, weil du da keinen Einfluss zu nehmen kannst im Grunde genommen, wie die Antje sagt, das ist selbst organisiert. Also da eben müsste es sich von selbst geben, in der idealen Welt. Genau, da ergibt sich das von selbst.
Naja, also ich fand das schon interessant. Im Millenton gab es ja, da wart ihr zu Gast im St. Pauli-Podcast, sehr empfehlenswert an der Stelle. Und da gab es jetzt eine Folge Mythos Ultra. Und da waren zwei Gründungsmitglieder von USP. Und einer von beiden war wohl auf einer Podiumsdiskussion, ich denke, es war im Rahmen eurer Ausstellung, und wurde da gefragt, warum gibt es eigentlich keine Vorsängerinnen. Und da hat er im Podcast, hat er gesagt, ja damals habe ich noch sehr ausweichend geantwortet, aber das hat bei ihm einen Gedankenprozess angestoßen. Und er saß dann ein paar Wochen später beim Millenton und hat gesagt, nee, eigentlich bin ich jetzt schon dafür, dass wir das jetzt einfach mal machen und dass es eigentlich auch sein muss, weil es wird nicht von alleine passieren. Und das fand ich absolut bemerkenswert. Auch weil sein USP-Kollege gleich, bitte was, bist du noch der, den ich kenne? Also war auch eine interessante Dynamik. Aber das zeigt ja, dass das schon was anstoßen kann, wenn man das auch wirklich mal konkretisiert. So absurd es sich vielleicht anhört, gerade auch in so ja doch zwar hierarchischen, aber doch auch anarchischen Jugendstrukturen, Kulturen.
Ich glaube, es macht zumindest auch in Fan- oder Ultragruppen mal Sinn, darüber zu sprechen, wer hat welche Positionen, wie ist die Rollenverteilung und welche Rollen und Positionen haben zum Beispiel auch Frauen in unserer Gruppe und welche Problemstellungen gibt es da? Weil ich glaube da schon, dass die wenigsten Ultragruppen jetzt darüber reden. Man kann auch entschuldigend sagen, natürlich ist das Tagesgeschäft auch immer sehr vollgepackt und viele wichtige und auch vielleicht sogar für die Gruppen in dem Fall relevantere oder wichtigere Themen, aber allein mal über sowas ins Gespräch zu kommen und zu gucken, gibt es nicht auch für die Frauen, die da in der Position werden oder Rolle, die man sich vorstellen kann. Also im Endeffekt, wenn man es ausprobiert, muss man dann gucken, ob es funktioniert. Und auch glaube ich, bei USP gab es mal eine Frau auf dem Zaun und dann hieß es ein bisschen so, es hat irgendwie nicht gut funktioniert und da kam, da ist das Feuer, der Funke nicht übergesprungen. Das muss eine Vorsängerin oder ein Vorsänger ja auch irgendwie leisten. Und dann schaut man eben weiter, aber man hat es zumindest gemacht und versucht und da sollten sich vielleicht auch die Ultra-Gruppen definitiv dann öffnen, das mal auszuprobieren und nicht Angst zu haben. Aber ich kenne auch das Beispiel aus Bremen, da gab es mal die Diskussion von einer Ultra-Gruppe, da hat die Ultra-Gruppe selber quasi eine Frau, na nicht gefordert, aber gefragt, machst du das? Und das wäre voll cool, das wäre voll wichtig, das wäre voll das Zeichen und die hat es dann gemacht, aber hat sich irgendwie sau unwohl gefühlt, auch mit dieser Rolle und der Position, weil es glaube ich ganz schön krass ist, wenn du auf einmal auf so einen Männer mehr schaust und sehr präsent sein musst und das eigentlich gar nicht so dein Ding ist und du vielleicht sogar auch Beleidigungen und so negative Erfahrungen dann in dem Fall machst. Deswegen muss man halt immer schauen, aber klar, man kann auf jeden Fall das auch mal vielleicht als Gedankenanstoß mit auf den Weg geben, dass man auch mal darüber redet in der Gruppe und darüber nachdenkt, aber wie gesagt, es muss auch irgendwie von der Situation, von der Chemie, von der Persönlichkeit her dann passen.
Also ich würde da auch ganz definitiv die Fanprojekte in der Pflicht sehen, da entsprechende Diskussionen anzuregen, auf alle Fälle das Thema da auch mit reinzubringen. Die Fanprojekte Ippla, da gibt es jetzt ja Weiterbildungen auch und Schulungen etc. Das ist nicht mehr so viel vor 20 Jahren, aber ich sehe da doch noch einen sehr, sehr großen Bedarf, auch eben Nachholbedarf, eben geschlechterspezifische Arbeit eben auch und eben auch die Gleichberechtigung, wie das dann da reingebracht wird in die Fankurve. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt meines Erachtens.
Obwohl ich mir da weniger wünschen würde, dass eine Fanprojekterin oder Fanprojekter mal zu einer Ultragruppe geht und sagt, hier wie sieht es denn aus bei euch mit der Frauenquote?
So nicht, ne, ne.
Vorsehnerin possessed, sondern dass sie halt was vorleben auch, weil gerade die teilweise Dinge einfach extrem reproduzieren auch. Und das ist einfach, dass sie merken, okay ich mache auch geschlechtsspezifische oder geschlechterreflektierte Arbeit hier gerade, weil ich mit einem Männerdomäne arbeite und mit jungen und jungen Männern, adolescenten Männern, die sich gerade zu Männern entwickeln. Und Männlichkeit ist total das Thema, also mit denen arbeite ich und deswegen bin ich auch ein Pädagoge in dem Feld, dass da allein dieses Verständnis da ist, ist auf jeden Fall schon wichtig, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist der allererste Schritt, genau, der ist eigentlich für mich Grundvoraussetzung, wenn ich in diesem Beruf arbeite, ist ja natürlich nicht überall gegeben, aber der zweite Schritt wäre aber schon, so was mal anzugehen, also einfach so Sachen anzustoßen, Diskussionen anzustoßen, wie du gesagt hast, Antje, dass das eben, in vielen Gruppen kommst du nicht von selbst raus, aber das mal reinzubringen und einen Film zu zeigen oder Beispiele zu nennen und damit zu einer Gruppe einfach zu reden, das sehe ich schon auch als Filmprojektarbeit an.
Ja, auch da mal Schulungen zu machen, also zum Beispiel, mein Verein ist jetzt auch total interessiert daran, da Schulungen und sowas zu machen, nur die gibt es dann zum Teil auch nicht. Also hatten wir jetzt auch mit Fußballfans gegen Homophobie öfters mal überlegt und also da hat Fortuna jetzt auch mehrfach nachgefragt, aber aufgrund natürlich, wir wissen jetzt, aufgrund der Ausstellung und alles ist das so ein bisschen hinten runtergefallen. Aber ich glaube zum Teil ist auch Interesse da, aber das Angebot muss halt dann auch noch ausgeweitet werden und also im Bereich Fanbetreuung und Fanprojekt fände ich eine Quote wirklich sehr sinnvoll, weil es einfach auch wichtig ist, gerade bei den jungen Leuten, dass da auch mal die Mädels eine weibliche Ansprechpartnerin haben. Also das finde ich wirklich enorm wichtig, weil da gibt es einfach viele Sachen, mit denen gerade junge Frauen nicht zu einem Mann gehen. Also und halt oder wie wir vorhin schon angesprochen hatten im Bereich sexualisierte Gewalt oder so, da ist es halt einfach häufig so, dass man halt nicht mit einem Mann darüber reden möchte, wenn man gerade von einem Mann irgendwie angegriffen wurde. Also das hat nichts mit Qualifikation zu tun und also da ist man dann ja auch häufig als Frau dann oder als ungeschulte Frau so ein bisschen, also wir machen das jetzt auch aus der Fanszene heraus, so Ansprechpartner und so weiter, wollen uns aber auch erstmal schulen, weil bloß weil ich eine Frau bin, heißt das ja nicht, dass ich immer richtig reagiere. Also da muss man sich dann ja auch einfach weiterbilden und ich finde, also wenn man sowas aus der Fanszene anstößt und der Verein da mitarbeitet, dann kann man auch sagen, so aber in einem Jahr oder so macht ihr das alleine. Wir wissen, das ist jetzt zu kurzfristig, ihr habt das Personal gerade nicht, aber wir fangen das jetzt mit euch an und nächstes Jahr habt ihr da jemanden, also dass man das so einfach zusammen macht. Also man muss ja nicht immer nur fordern, sondern kann auch so einfach gemeinsam daran arbeiten.
Ach, in der Theorie ist es alles immer dann doch irgendwie einfach. Ich frage mich ja auch, warum, also meine Hoffnung war mal so ein bisschen, aber die Hoffnung ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre alt und wurde einer ernüchternden Realität gegenüber gestellt, aber meine Theorie war mal vor vier Jahren, dass im Mittelbau von Bundesligisten oder Fußballvereinen generell, also sprich in der Scouting-Abteilung, in der Talentförderung, dass da mal Frauen reinkommen, weil es gibt ja keinen Grund, warum eine Frau nicht ein genauso guter Scout oder taktischer Analystin sein sollte, wie ein Mann. Aber dann habe ich da mal mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen und die waren so erstaunt, dass ich gefragt habe, waren denn hier eigentlich überhaupt mal Frauen, man macht ja dann so, kann ja Lizenzen erwerben und so weiter, kann sich da ausbilden, und da haben die so große Augen bekommen und da war die Antwort immer, ja mal die eine, die war mal Nationalspielerin, die macht jetzt was für die Frauen Nationalmannschaft. Das war die Antwort, die ich da immer bekommen habe, deswegen hat sich diese Hoffnung nicht erfüllt. Man sieht jetzt ein paar mehr Ärztinnen oder Physiotherapeutinnen auf den Bänken, gibt es aber auch schon genügend Geschichten, was die sich so anhören mussten in den Stadien. Aber das war eine Hoffnung, die hatte ich mal, inzwischen sehe ich da, also vielleicht kommt es noch.
Weibliche Trainerinnen, also da gibt es ja noch weniger Grund, warum nicht eine Frau- und Männerteam trainieren soll und da gab es ja auch mal ein paar, aber die wurden so was von angefallen, dass sie glaube ich innerhalb kürzester Zeit dann eher in eine Klinik mussten, also das ist schon krass zum Teil. Aber da kann man dann auch wirklich in der Jugendarbeit anfangen, also wenn das halt einmal so von klein auf gelernt wurde, wie es jetzt halt von klein auf gelernt wurde, dass Frauen dann nichts zu suchen haben.
Also ich glaube, das ist auch so eine Sache, die wird sich über Generationen vielleicht verändern, aber es ist halt schon interessant, dass es eigentlich kaum ein Thema ist, dass im Frauenfußball gerade ja auch unter anderem FC Bayern ja jetzt trennen sich jetzt am Ende der Saison von ihrem Trainer, aber da ist es völlig normal, dass ein Mann Trainer einer Frauenmannschaft ist und umgedreht wäre es aber völlig undenkbar. Da gab es, glaube ich, mal einen Fall bei einem italienischen Zweitligisten oder so ähnlich.
In Frankreich auch.
In Frankreich auch, stimmt, genau. Und es gab mal kurz die Überlegung, Birgit Prinz hatte mal das Angebot von einem italienischen, ich glaube Erstligisten sogar, dass sie quasi in die Männermannschaft wechseln soll. Aber da hat sie auch dann damals gesagt, ne, also das will sie sich nicht antun, auch wenn sie es irgendwie schon mal gereizt hätte, da mitzuspielen.
Es gibt auch das Positivbeispiel aus China, Shan Yuting ist vor zwei Jahren mit ihrem Team Meisterin geworden. Es gibt so rudimentär als als Trainerin in der Männermannschaft. Es gibt schon so Beispiele und langsam geht das vielleicht dann auch irgendwie weiter.
Und da kommt es rein. Ja, aber was da auch eine Rolle spielt, ist sicherlich die Erziehung von den Jungs in den Fußballvereinen. Und da sage ich jetzt eben wirklich auch Jungs, wenn es um Männerfußball geht, dass auch das eine Rolle spielt. Wie ist da der Umgang untereinander? Wie ist da der Sprachton? Welche Sachen werden da genannt? Spielt doch nicht wie ein Mädchen, sei doch nicht verweichlicht etc. Da fängt es ja schon an in der E- und D-Jugend im Grunde genommen mit den Bildern, die da im Kopf ablaufen.
Ja, aber auch die Eltern. Es gibt ja auch Mädchen, die in der Jungmannschaft spielen, wie die angefeindet werden. Da gab es jetzt auch auf Twitter ein berühmtes Beispiel, wo eine Mutter mal was gepostet hat, was dann um die ganze Welt gegangen ist. Das Mädchen wurde jetzt auch von der englischen Nationalmannschaft eingeladen. Da haben sich dann auch ganz viele Frauen im Fußball aus allen Bereichen dahinter gestellt und auch so ein bisschen dann eigene Erfahrungen geschildert, wie es für sie früher war. Und haben dann dem kleinen Mädchen Mut gemacht. Und eigentlich glaube ich, jede Profisportlerin kann da ihre Geschichte erzählen. Also das ist auch immer schreckend, dass das heute noch so ist. Also ich frage mich dann auch, was so in Köpfen von so Eltern vorgeht.
Ich glaube, dass alles Erziehung ist. Weil wenn du entsprechend erzogen wirst, dann hast du dafür einen Blick. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe nie darüber nachgedacht, ob ich Frauen im Rasenfunk haben möchte, weil ich wurde sehr feministisch erzogen und dann hast du das einfach so gespürt dafür. Ja, das kannst du, aber es ist extrem schwierig. Und da brauchst du eine intrinsische Motivation und wo soll die herkommen. Und extrinsisch funktioniert es halt schwieriger, weil da blocken die Leute ja ab, weil die sagen, lass mich in Ruhe. Ja, aber vielleicht überinterpretiere ich das auch aus meiner persönlichen Sozialisation.
Ich wahrscheinlich auch, also mir wurde ja früher das Fußballspielen verboten. Und was habe ich gemacht? Ich bin dann Fan geworden, ich bin das schwarze Schaf der Familie. Aber man kann auch aus einer Nicht-Fußball-Familie zur Fußballmännchen werden. Aber es ist deutlich schwerer, ja.
Ja gut, das habe ich auch hingekriegt. Aber das ist jetzt eine andere Geschichte. Vielleicht abschließend noch, ich hoffe, das hören jetzt auch viele Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, die sagen, da waren jetzt Punkte für mich dabei, wo ich vielleicht auch entweder weiterlesen möchte, dann sollen sie in die Show Notes gucken und sich da engagieren, aber wo sie vielleicht auch sagen, ich möchte irgendwie mitarbeiten daran, dass sich die Situation dann doch langsam verbessert. Und jetzt gibt es ja unter anderem das Frauen im Fußballnetzwerk. Könnt ihr mal kurz erklären, wenn jetzt Hörerinnen da draußen sagen, sie hätten überhaupt erstmal Interesse an diesen Vernetzungsgedanken und dann zu gucken, ob man da vielleicht dann selbst etwas verändern kann? Was müsste man denn dafür tun? Oder Frau in dem Fall?
Der erste Punkt wäre vielleicht mal auf Facebook zu gehen oder auf die Homepage von Femme Frauen im Fußball. Da gibt es sonst auch eine Mail-Adresse und einen Mail-Verteiler. Und man kann das sozusagen einmal im Jahr mit anderen Frauen vernetzen bei einem Netzwerktreffen. Das war ja dieses Jahr zum Beispiel in Düsseldorf und wird nächstes Jahr in Jena sein, im, glaube ich, letzten Juni-Wochenende, wo alle Frauen willkommen sind, sich sozusagen unter den Rahmenbedingungen, dass sie nicht sozusagen diskriminierend sind oder sozusagen rechts sind, vernetzen können, austauschen können.
Da wird dann auch die Tastic Females-Ausstellung sein.
Genau, da schließt sich der Kreis wieder. Also man kann auf jeden Fall, weil es auch eine sehr unheirarchisch organisierte Struktur ist, sich auch selber einbringen. Genau, wie man sozusagen gerade lustig ist. Dinge, Themen problematisieren, ansprechen. Wir schreiben Stellungnahmen, machen Sticker. Leute von uns sind mit Vorträgen unterwegs.
Also das wäre auch so die beste Adresse, wo man mal so Anschluss findet.
Genau, würde ich sagen. Also wer Lust auf einen Austausch hat, aber mit Fußballbezug auf jeden Fall, ist da genau eine richtige Adresse, würde ich sagen.
Ja und ansonsten, also auf jeden Fall sich einfach auch mal im eigenen Verein umgucken und vielleicht selber Dinge anstoßen. Also jetzt zum Beispiel in Dortmund hat die Ramona, die auch bei Fentastic Females war und jetzt auch beim Fynn-Treffen, glaube ich, war ihr erstes, hat danach dann einfach ein Twitter-Treffen für weibliche Fußballfans ins Leben gerufen. Oder in Düsseldorf haben wir über Vernetzungen in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren und auch die Organisation des Fynn-Treffens haben wir jetzt eine eigene Frauengruppe gegründet. Und also dass man, man muss auch nicht immer so in die Ferne gucken. Man kann auch mal so links und rechts neben sich gucken. Und wenn man dann einfach so eine Idee mal startet, dann melden sich auch automatisch so viele andere Frauen. Oder wenn man mal ein bisschen rumstenkert und was sagt, dann kommen auf einmal ganz viel Feedback aus dem ganzen Verein. Oh, toll, dass ihr das angesprochen habt. Und ich habe gedacht, wenn ich das sage, dann hört mir eh keiner zu. Und also so, wenn man sich mal traut, den ersten Schritt zu machen, dann wird man ganz viel auch positives Feedback bekommen. Und daraus ergeben sich dann wieder andere Projekte und Ideen und Aktionen. Also man kann auch einfach selber mal was starten.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist dann für die mit der hohen Eigenmotivation und dem hohen Selbstbewusstsein und diejenigen, denen es daran noch mangelt, die können sich ja erst mal vernetzen und dann geht's ja von da an los. Und das soll aber nicht alle Männer, die das jetzt hier hören, aus der Verantwortung rausnehmen. Es gibt noch viel zu tun, aber es geht ja auch voran. Ich glaube, auch wenn ich noch wirklich sehr lange mit euch reden könnte, weil es auch so eine besonders nette Runde ist, obwohl wir nicht alle in einem Raum sitzen, finde ich, ist es ein sehr schönes Gespräch. Aber so langsam bringen wir es dann zum Ende. Und es muss ja nicht die letzte derartige Folge gewesen sein. Deswegen bedanke ich mich sehr herzlich bei euch, und zwar noch mal namentlich bei jedem jetzt. Danke, liebe Angel. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Viel Erfolg mit Werder und mit der Ausstellung. Danke für deine Zeit. Na, wenn ihr bis ins Champions League-Finale kommt, dann sehen wir uns international. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Sue Rudolf, die Ad-Medien-Freundin auf Twitter. Sue, vielen Dank dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Wir sehen uns dann in der Allianz Arena, wenn ihr gegen die glorreiche Fatouna Haushofer verlieren werdet.
Na ja, Konton könnt ihr ja tatsächlich sehr gut. Schauen wir mal, ob wir uns im Stadion am Kurt-Landauer-Weg, natürlich, ob wir uns da treffen werden. Und außerdem herzlichen Dank, dass du hergekommen bist in mein rotes Büro, Steffi Dilber.
Ja, hat mich sehr gefreut. Ja, so rot ist es ja glücklicherweise gar nicht.
Nein, so rot bin ich ja auch dann doch irgendwie nicht. Ich komme auf eine deiner 60-Führung, wenn du mal wieder eine machst. Das würde mich sehr interessieren.
Und die ganzen Aufkleber, die die Steffi geklebt hat, die wirst du auch noch entdecken.
Ja gut, das kriege ich ja besonders mit. Der Weg zum Kindergarten führt sehr nah am Trainingsgelände des FC Bayern vorbei. Und da gibt es halt ein paar Graffiti- und Stickerspots, wo du immer siehst, fast täglich werden da Dinge überklebt, abgerissen, wieder überklebt, wieder abgerissen. Das ist fast schon eine Materialschlacht, wenn ihr mich fragt. Aber Sticker sind da günstig. Ja gut, aber es ist ein guter Hinweis, muss ich noch mal gucken, in welchen Räumen du heute schon alles warst. Wenn ich noch mal alles suche. Also ich danke euch allen sehr und ich danke auch allen Hörern und Hörern für die Aufmerksamkeit, das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 26. Hört auch das Tribünengespräch zu Fußball Podcasts, schaut euch alles an und geht vor allem unbedingt in die Ausstellung und kommt sie nicht in eure Nähe, dann beschwert euch nicht drüber, sondern organisiert, dass sie selbst hinkommt. Ihr könnt es selbst anpacken. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, wir hören uns wieder in der nächsten Rasfunk-Folge. Bis dahin eine gute Zeit euch.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.